it's one of those things that you can't
hide wherever you go you are the doctor
well it's okay because these guys didn't
know what it was yeah you could hide
backstage yeah it's an interesting it's
an interesting thing particularly a
Briton but weirdly the show you can't
predict a demographic it's it's all over
the world
and so the reason that thing where you
go okay so you know I'm walking around
this place I don't need my hat and then
the oddest kind of moment will happen
and you go on
maybe they recognize Moe but if you're
me you have a slight narcissism what you
think everyone's recognizing you that's
such an embarrassing thing I have this
read yesterday all the Jew so is it I've
always to got like Oh anyway right
basically what happened so I stood on
Oxford Tube platform yeah
and I've always got em so you know like
a glass keep coupe you know like it
rather than going to a coffee shop and
get in a new cup
I carry a glass one that are then wash
and reget malate and so I got I got my
empty cup and I was just stood at down
stuff and an elderly gentleman was
walking towards me on the platform I was
just so I just just wanna get on the
tube recognized then he had his arm out
and his am came into my space and on the
tube on the platform it's crowded and
it's a bit I don't know I just got the
candle I I were doing a bit aggressive
unnecessarily and actually what he was
doing was he when I saw I thought you
wanted money
[Applause]
I was like some make eye contacts I can
tell this story you can't hide you can't
put ask I mean but yeah I I mean I've
seen you in a gym like at a public gym
so do you get you get bothered all the
time all the time yeah how do you gone
out the window how do you work out in
the gym of people to constantly give me
help to you
just be nice say hello get a-movin but
fame is a funny thing right so you have
that story for you well that will be
like the constant anchoring reminder
right like how cool Fame is but also
never like I don't have the stress you
have though because I think the thing is
if you if you are five or six and you've
got hat on and you dressed like a most
the time a teenage boy in a baseball cap
headphones on head down I catch the bus
and the I catch the bus on the subway
every single day because I'm not in
anyone's eye line like that but I
imagine you there is something about if
if you're you you can't
Kevin's had weird you've had weird fan
okay well what happens if you're three
foot two like
how do you deal with that
- I'm sorry I think well first is -
we're skipping around some points here
first thing saying she's dressed like a
teenage boy that somebody put money in
your cup it's got to be a lot worse
tonight something within your parents
said I need to help this person make
sure they eat today for me I mean it's
it's bad and because I'm a big deal
it's just it seems I follow was in a
restaurant we followed you oh my god I
had a I had a guy actually followed me
into the bathroom is it true story uh
I'm in a stall you know I gotta go and
you know guys while I'm in the bathroom
that Kevin can I get a picture and I'm
like you know cuz I'm obviously a very
big guy I myself immediately I said hey
not in here
you wait until I'm done okay you go
outside I'll take it with you when I get
outside then I go in the stall it closed
the door and you know you would expect
whoever that was to have left there
they're gone and I you know I do what I
got to do when it was a it was one of
those situations where I had to be in
there for a while
you know literally you know when you
when you get comfortable you start to
take your time and I'm on my phone I'm
scrolling I'm you know it's just it's a
it's a it's a comfortable and got what
you do at the ball I get done and I like
get out the stall and close the doors
right there he's in there for a while
can we get the picture I was like I met
outside the bathroom I'm not taking a
picture - in a bathroom but the fact
that he stood there like very nicely
though it made me feel obligated I was
like hey justjust come on Sophie okay
buddy you saw me in here Jason Statham
evers yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you